party's coalition is exploding at the
moment joe biden's support among
hispanics is the lowest among any ethnic
group in the united states who saw that
coming and the effects of it are
demonstrable
so just the other day a special election
took place in the rio grande valley in
texas
meyer flores republican flipped a
congressional seat that democrats have
held for over a century it's really an
amazing story she joins us for her first
interview since being sworn in as a
member of congress congresswoman flores
i really appreciate your coming on thank
you so much congratulations on your win
it's it's amazing what does it mean
exactly how did you do this it would
have been unimaginable 10 years ago
honestly i just focus on the issues that
really matter to my district and you
know we're all about faith family and
hard work that's exactly who we are
and so
yeah but i mean it was an overwhelmingly
democratic district
so yeah but you know we didn't have the
funding before we didn't have the
funding before to get the message across
our district and now we do have the
funding and the support from the
republican party but prior to 2020 we
did not have that support we were all
alone you know the democrat party took
us for granted and we also did not have
the support from the republican party
and that's you know that's uh that's a
fact
yeah nobody thought it was possible no i
think i think that in in washington so
faith family hard work
yes that's who we are that's who we've
always been you know people tell me myra
why are you republican weren't you born
in mexico well because i was born in
mexico is that i am republican because i
was raised with strong conservative
values and i'm not willing to put them
aside for a political party and i'm not
loyal to a party i'm loyal to god i'm
loyal to my family i'm loyal to my
community and i tell the people in south
texas who are you loyal to are you loyal
to god or are you loyal to the democrat
party and they tell me no i'm loyal to
god okay well let's stop being loyal to
a party who's done nothing for us for
over 100 years
i don't think you're allowed to say i'm
loyal to god now that you're in
washington are you going to keep saying
that absolutely my loyalty is to god and
my family yes absolutely god first all
the way that's why i won because of him
because i live in prayer every single
day
i just i just love this oh i love it
good luck in washington i hope you enjoy
it i they're they're gonna tell me
they're gonna make you try and stop
saying that but i hope you'll continue
my floor absolutely not
great great to see